now to actress alyssa milano opening up
about her battle with coronavirus
i just wanted to show you the amount of
hair that's coming out of my head as a
result
of uh covered as you can see
in there there is no hair
in there right now
[Music]
one brushing this is my hair loss
from covid19 it may be
you know her own antibodies that are
affecting these hair follicles
because you know there's other things
that cause hair loss one of the biggest
things
is stress and you know she has to be
stressed to the max
just the fact that she has coded 19. the
doctor's co-host dr andrew orton is
acutely aware of covid19 symptoms
he recovered from the virus early in the
outbreak i rested
and i isolated myself and fortunately
i did not infect anybody else meanwhile
actor antonio banderas revealed he too
has coronavirus
he announced it yesterday on his 60th
birthday he's in quarantine and says
he's okay
except for being a little bit more tired
than usual
of course antonio and alyssa aren't
alone i
woke up in the middle of the night and
couldn't breathe i had body aches
crippling cracking body aches
i'm very thankful for everyone who's
been there to help me
it came back positive yeah and it
sucks i was very fortunate i had very
mild symptoms
six-time emmy winner brian cranston told
et he posted this video at an la blood
bank to raise awareness
i feel it's my responsibility to donate
plasma
for those people that i i ache
for who who are in real trouble it
really does
help people ease their suffering and
maybe even save some lives